One of the most basic constitutional responsibilities that are prosecutor has is
to disclose or to turn over to the defense exculpatory evidence.
That is evidence that might suggest that the person accused of the crime is
actually innocent of the crime.
The Supreme Court has held that that's a constitutional responsibility of
prosecutors.
That failure to turn over that evidence has often been what's led to the
conviction of innocent people.
One of those innocent people as John Thompson,
uh,
who was,
arrested on January,
1985 in New Orleans when he was just 22 years old,
accused in two separate crimes,
one of arm robbery and the other of murder,
uh,
ultimately convicted of those crimes.
He spent 18 years in the custody,
uh,
of the Louisiana prison system,
14 of those years on death row and he came very close to being executed on May
the 20th,
1999.
I want to ask John Thompson what happened to pick up the story at this point and
tell us what happened just as he was there within a month of execution.
Uh,
John Thompson,
welcome.
Thank you for joining us.
Could you pick up the story and tell us what happened there in the days right
before you were to be put to death by the state of Louisiana?
Oh,
well,
you know how much
he was interested in the DC there,
it'll to the fact that we had nearly exhausted all my remedies,
all a with the cold house.
Um,
it was nothing else for them to do other than trying to find a way to maybe even
filed ineffective sister.
The is on themselves.
These,
this was trying to look at the feeling that I did.
They'd be down the feel me.
So the first thing they told me that when he was trying to do is I was kind of
shocked and I asked him not to do that to himself,
but hire some more investigators.
And that's what they did,
um,
with,
with nothing else left to do.
We had two cases,
our own robbery case when I received it,
49 and a half years.
But it happened maybe two weeks after the murder happened.
Um,
um,
[inaudible] was looking for a five feet,
seven description with a big Bush.
Um,
the murder suspect was,
uh,
six feet tall with about,
hey,
um,
so the city's two incidents happen two weeks apart.
My lawyer was really,
you know,
a meal.
It's about the fact that he prosecuted the same individual at both descriptions.
And so I was always trying to prove it's hard.
Like it's one of the,
it's hard to try to convince a group of lawyers that you're innocent of one
charge that's Donald to say,
hold out,
I'm going to send that both of these charges.
It really didn't have them really take to really won the fight it at first until
everything else was out the door.
My murder case was drew.
So once we decided to take a bone and they hired another investigator that can
come in with totally new eyes,
totally new view,
it would just basically,
because I was totally out of any other appeals or any other opportunity for the
say and my like,
um,
holding the whole riding off the top.
At the first beginning of the transcript of my transcript,
what was asked was it was a tricky situation.
It was emotion to emotion.
I was just going to in the arrangement to plead guilty or not guilty to the
murder charge and they'll still in the course to meet going into the courtroom
to plead guilty to the murder charge three their kids was in a coat and identify
me at that time and said that I am an appropriate training and robbed them.
The district attorney and let it be known that I was identified and open code
and survivor suspect.
My attorneys at the time was thinking,
I'm just going in there for arrangement for the murder and so they started
arguing the case with the district attorney and the judge saying that this is a
very unfair identification.
Mr. Thompson coming in the code by herself,
but deep thinking that I was being identified in the murder case,
but I will.
Are you sure you're brought into court?
You're the only person who's a defendant and these three witnesses are there and
they identify you as being the perpetrator of this crime.
The crown,
I'm on robbing him right now given take debt.
The DVD stop.
The perpetrator has been five feet,
seven with a big Bush.
Right.
Although that one wasn't my height and my test out at the time when I was a
restaurant.
Right.
They look you down a five to seven man with a ball.
Hey,
because the system,
when you first get arrested,
the first thing he did,
and he was put on my hell because he was trying to make me look like the safe
speed tall ball.
Hey man,
the committed the murder rate and I lose them.
All right.
Crimes.
There are two weeks apart.
One is the arm robbery and one is the murder when they're saying the same person
can commit both crimes,
even though the descriptions were completely different,
completely different.
The murder happened first decent.
The robbery happened second.
So when you arrested me,
when you realized that I don't have no,
so what happened was in the course of them being on evaluating how to proceed
with this particular case,
the District Attorney Office,
I'm sorry,
I'm speaking,
turns up deep,
brought me into this.
Um,
very um,
how they favorable to them.
Suggestion of identifying me as a perpetrator,
but because of my lawyer's in them thinking that I was being identified as a
murder,
the argument case,
Dni really paying attention to what the other district attorney is asking.
The judge,
the other district attorney is asking the to help all of my blog withdraw,
right.
Because uh,
evidence obviously that was definitely in the scene of the crime.
And so what happened was,
um,
my lawyers will sit so busy argue with them about the identification.
He didn't even hear the request,
but once he realized in my lawyers came to conclusion that this wasn't about the
murder,
not even all the way back,
all the way up deed,
it backed up off the arguments and getting them back.
They went to saying,
oh,
we can't be on this case no longer.
We don't want to represent Mr. Thompson no longer.
That's what the conversation went to wall once g real and I just was totally
different.
There was about a whole new issue.
Then it was the same saying where we out to get it to other cases.
We needed to get off of this case right now.
And the judge refused to let them off the case and he made them be my attorney.
But go back to the original thing was dia Pernick,
this deputy public defender Office to represent me in these robbery cases,
that same public defender off it.
They say he couldn't represent me in a murder case.
That's was why I was here with,
that's is why it was two weeks.
Two weeks later I'm at this arrangement for my murder.
I had to go through finding me private at the tournaments because the public
defender office say he couldn't represent me in this murder case because I was
someone that,
um,
he offers building that I was guilty and he feels his office building like that.
They know the victim family.
So Mr Bartaile said,
not only could,
I can't represent them,
I don't believe nobody in my office could represent him in this matchup.
So the blood turned out to be very important evidence in the last days of what
was supposed to be the last days of your life.
Right,
exactly.
So,
so,
so how to process when we are assuming I'm just a sec of exception now.
Dad,
I was bonding Charity Hospital Walden's,
you know,
so it wasn't hard for them to find out what my blood type was.
As the district attorney on thing you got to do is call and we'll just call the
hospital and realize you just ask him about my blood type.
We need to them and for me.
So we had the district attorney and never following up that request that he made
from the judge.
They have my blood with drunk.
He found out that that answer without having my blood drawn,
so the d d d I didn't take this armed robbery case and pursue it before he
pursued the murder case.
So they decided to prosecute me for this armed robbery case.
You got three little kids saying that I'm the one Robin.
They got Newman,
Brodie,
I represented me.
Mister Birkdale office claimed that he couldn't represent me in the murder,
but all of a sudden he could represent me,
not in this robbery kid.
I tried to protest it.
It didn't go because I couldn't afford attorney Cosa,
you're going to get with Dakota Punch him.
So I was supposed to go to trial with mister Bartell.
Mr. Bird tell,
waiting til the last day of the trial,
the day before my trial to come and see me for the before your trial.
They did.
Before my child was the first time I seen him.
Mr. Byrd.
Tell your lawyer,
your defense lawyer at the trial.
The first time you saw your defense lawyer,
the trial was the night before your trot fill my job.
Lucy was the first time when this incident happened.
Wendy said just robbery spool the head to the place.
So once he told me when the robbery took place,
I would just feel back and relief because I realized where I was at democratic
in the day.
I knew I was at work and I know I a coop.
I was at work.
I know I could have witnesses to come and testify that I was at work and that's
just what happened.
I was able to tell him,
Mr Borcella,
where to go and find my way to see who the Brennon Ducote and how to talk to
them.
They're fine.
And that one night he was able to do just that.
So he was able to bring him back to testify that next day in coke for me,
four or five of them are cool workers,
time seats,
my supervisor and all.
So these kids said he was robbed by the Super Dome.
I was working at the Mr. Ball,
the turtle that night.
It was December the 28th when he said [inaudible] Tornado,
that's the first start of Mardi gras season.
So I know where I was at Delta by grabbed Grandpa,
I'm just to get paid five,
$600 cash money.
Why would I go out and try to ride kids?
Alright,
so they tried to say,
I changed you in the phones.
I put it on from black to two genes and go ride the kids who come back and
change back into telling you on the phone.
They made it seem like these people have worked.
Couldn't actually account for me for eight hours.
Go on and say I was there and he seen me at one given time.
But the DAC,
I left and ran into Robert Kids and came back.
And do it.
That's how he went off and Spanish.
The German bleed you because the three kids were saying,
I did it.
Never at my trial did anything about blood came up.
No nothing.
And then blood evidence was touching him from the scene of the crime.
Doug was saying that we heard about a struggle to plagues,
but nothing was saying about blood evidence or anything.
Come to find out the day of my trial,
they just took attorney,
went to the evidence room,
the collect all the physical evidence and through the physical evidence of
weight,
drew the blood pants,
tennis shoes away,
drew the blood,
uh,
pants,
leg,
the weight that was confiscated from the crime scene when,
when the robbery first took place,
when the robbery took place,
it was a scuffle between the perpetrator and the victim.
One of the victims,
excuse me,
that struggled led to,
um,
blood being left on the victim pants,
leg and tennis shoes.
That was from the perpetrator.
Um,
the police confiscated that blood immediately.
Time he came to the scene.
At the time that blood went straight to the crime,
they have to be tested.
That's why the DA,
the first question was from the district attorney during the course of me being
identified in Oakland coat to have my requesting that the judge had my blood
withdraw to what's the judge granted that motion to the defense.
Um,
and I can say them just investigate it.
They quickly recognize
our request for my blood was me at the beginning of,
of her transcript when she first began my investigation.
When it's charged,
it's first came about.
So she looked at the transcript to find out what happened.
And when I was first initially charged with this case,
my first court appearance,
and that's the first thing she recognized the coke was Sam has a dead tied dead
into play.
Even though all the other argument was going on,
she did type in the request that the da May in the judge responds granting him
that request to have my blow withdraw.
All right.
Never did he ever come to have my glove withdrawal?
Never did Mr and ever knew anything about blog existed in this crime at all.
Um,
when to see is when all this was first discovered when,
when we first discovered the blog was evidence he did have blood out with them.
So they win first day and he went back to do it.
They'll get their evidence.
We went straight to the with and seeing all the evidence that was collected,
police reports and so forth.
Right,
exactly.
Then we recognize in a,
in a bunch of the murder
and the murder trial in a bunch of the Nada police repurposed a lot of different
cool police reports with stuff in it.
It really just didn't make sense to the murder case when we were quickly,
they realize that's where it did me simply because it belonged in a robber.
So it was obviously that dude was stuffing it in the murder trial to try to keep
it out of the robbery.
Um,
police report in,
in,
in breakfast at the district.
We turn it off.
It was all right,
but so when we really went through it and realize that this is what happened,
dance was taking him the physical evidence to the crime that she went straight
to the cloud and they have been to pick out where the evidence was,
what was happening.
We realized that the blood evidence had been tested and he had a final result of
the blood test and it was good and it was sent to the district attorney office
himself.
One of the district attorney himself wouldn't sign for the results of the
evidence and the end and so he claimed that he placed it on the Hay just to
return and dentist the head district attorney claim and he never seen me before,
but what did it say it that Mr. Thompson was exclusive?
I wasn't responsible.
It wasn't my blood.
Neither one was your blood type
me.
It just so half a month,
three is God.
My blood type was the same as the victim
and the perpetrator blood title was totally different and so it was that.
It was just a blessing that mean the victim had the same type of love.
Because if I had that other blog,
like the perpetrator hae like a lot of like majority of the people do have,
I think it was [inaudible].
I can't remember which way it was,
but I,
I know me and the victim is having a rare blood and you say we not,
you know,
normally the ones that you use to be a plentiful the other way around.
So I could easily been switched over on that side and out of being dead for a
crime I didn't commit.
What relationship time was there between when this was discovered that you could
not have possibly done this robbery and your execution date?
Maybe about,
I haven't gotten within 35 days I had to receive the date.
You know,
you can't give you the execution day.
You got to be 35 days and one right.
I hadn't received it 35 and the execution date I was scheduled to die me the
21st my son was scheduled to graduated me to talk to you.
So the result of that is your convictions for both the armed robbery and the
murder.
Of course the arm robbery was used at your murder trial to convict you and also
to keep you from testifying.
Is that right?
Yes.
Uh,
that was the whole block.
That was the whole strategy plan.
It was weird because even after the conviction,
so not as the Birch Hill fighting,
right.
Because now he realized that y'all are trying to railroad this innocent man.
He angled his people telling y'all he was at work and y'all still trying to
prosecute them.
So now this man,
they think I'm guilty of a murder nine.
He trying to fight when he just got too much against him.
It was like he had all the evidence.
Da deliberately went through it.
The physical evidence of weak it makes sure that he could never find that out
with this had never been returned back to the evidence room.
Um,
and I'm trying to figure out how deep just conspiracy it really was because you
got a person that work in the evidence room that that's his only job is when
people sign in and signing out the evidence.
So if you assign something that with this out,
they never bring him back.
No alarm doesn't go off.
He don't tell nobody that.
These district attorneys came and took some blood and with Dennis away from the
evidence room and didn't return it and we'll tell them nobody in his right now
he's back date having evidence.
I'm kind of like,
what kind of,
what?
Why do we have this procedure here if you're not going to notify someone when
someone lie to do not return physical evidence back and this,
that is a,
to me embarrassing to all come to justice system that caught alone.
We ain't got to go through nobody else bring the with.
That would have killed anything that was going on if he would've did this job.
Nobody even questioned him about his job as to this day.
He had yet to answer to why he did not notify someone when the district attorney
office didn't bring them that physical evidence back.
But at,
well I was just going to say tell us this.
I mean now you had a retrial right on both these charges,
right?
Yes.
And what happened
all the way during the robbery,
after the robbery conviction,
everybody understood I hadn't had the condition.
I wasn't,
I was a clean,
I had a decent rep.
So what happened was the my lawyers at my murder trial tried to ask the judge,
not the loud,
that conviction to be held against me because I want to take the stand and my
murder case.
Right.
And just to see if he'd take the stand,
I'm going to outlive the deed it using.
That's the law.
My Law told him,
my lawyer was kind,
smart Patrick fan who was a seasoned vet.
So Pat,
pat came back and told him,
well,
I won't put a writ to the full circuit court of appeal because this is not a
final conviction.
How can you use a condition that's not violent?
It hadn't even been on the pill yet.
Right.
And so in,
in,
in the judge say,
well,
if he get on that stand,
I'm allowed in the user,
take your Rick.
And so that's the best thing that could've happened to me.
Back to fandom.
Took that Richard the full sir and action.
Then I'm not allowed to cope to use that conviction against me.
The Pole circuit agreed with the judge and said that if I take the stand,
the DA got a right to use it.
This isn't your first trial.
This is a trial where you were convicted,
right?
Charles got convicted.
So now when I get the reversal flow design robbing,
it automatically opened up the door.
Doesn't the review my murder case dino,
would you just not see?
I requested through the coke represent all of that.
I wanted to testify in my own behalf.
Right.
Would you determine them to say that you are going to use this conviction
against me in depth?
Will you define me and my right to testify on her own behalf.
And so the full circle to bill came back and see.
Yeah,
lose a part of that.
And guess what y'all told me y'all was gonna use it against him.
So he needs everyone new trial.
So now going back to a new trial,
it's a whole different ball game now because now I'm just with the murder.
So not even know they don't have a case against me because they know the
perpetrator who committed the crime was the one that he cut the deal with Kevin
[inaudible].
They know
he was the person who accused you.
You're the person that kills me.
He fixed it.
The shift and six feet tall,
medium build,
bald head.
He fit the full description of all live witnesses a little we'll give,
districts are not saying anybody to have it.
Jill.
The fact that I didn't want to say that he did it,
that being ignored case and so the had to use him against me then because he had
to make a prohibition.
They didn't worry about that for once.
I wouldn't testify the way they want it.
That's when we put on robberies on me.
One,
I wouldn't tell them that Kevin Freeman did it.
He wanted me to say Kevin Freeman did it and I was there and I know it.
I don't know nothing.
I don't know Kevin Freeman did.
I wasn't with him.
If you know he did it,
convict him then
let me be sure I understand.
If you had been willing to say that Kevin had committed the crime and then you
were there,
they would've cut a deal with you.
Yes,
and instead they cut a deal with Kevin who apparently was the person who
committed the crime,
who got out of it by saying,
you did it.
Is that right?
Guest symbol as simple as ABC it was.
I can say one thing.
I do look at it,
look at it.
Before anybody was caught with all the witnesses were saying how to perpetrate
it.
Look,
and we just gave the same description.
Dean,
say the one person,
I mean,
no two people did it.
He said one,
Kevin Freeman with don of course,
and they put two people at the scene of the crime.
Well,
what happened at your second trial?
What happened when the jury,
you testified,
right,
and you told him you weren't there and and so forth.
Right.
I testify.
Well,
only that we found we had,
you know,
it was a lot more than about the blood.
They have a dense,
it's so much physical evidence,
ones going to tell from us and the robbery case as well.
Especially all of these other witnesses.
We didn't even know these other witnesses took place.
We didn't know they had all of these other witnesses and give different
descriptions.
We know we ain't nobody to hit all of these other witness.
Some witnesses was so scared that the move,
because you told the da they ain't demand.
I seen him running away and the da just ignored that witness.
And the witness got so scared,
did nothing to Walgreen's because you're saying that that man,
no,
I seen him and them ain't gonna come back and get me,
you know,
we had some incredible witness that can testify to things that,
that was withheld from us by these same district attorneys.
And so like you got right now,
the jury took less than the,
it took 30,
about 35 minutes all together after,
you know,
the best value for you to pick,
um,
a juror's hormones and all of that,
and then go over the evidence.
But I'm willing to show it by the two disciplines,
put it in the final foaming and the jury.
Then it took him to come back with a verdict and you know,
um,
they found you not guilty in 35 minutes.
Yes sir.
Good.
Spent 18 years in prison and 14 of those years on death row and the jury took 35
minutes to say,
you are not guilty.
[inaudible] all would happen.
All with the da Di [inaudible].
We was allowed because Freeman,
the person who testified,
it gives me to first job was d he was,
he was killed robbing somebody else.
You know,
people don't understand when we have these wrongful convictions.
And then you hear these stories like mine because he got some storage.
This is incredible.
Their mind,
you know this.
So when,
when we hit these acts are these district attorneys and we see this,
we don't look at,
I went,
this perpetrator did to someone else who gave him the right to unleash just
individual on the rest of the [inaudible] side.
So we,
and when we saying that we would all,
he destroyed in this one individual life,
we just looking at it like that.
But whatever that perpetrator,
he allowed to go.
I didn't command continue to hurt our society to tend to her sister.
This man was killed robbing someone else.
So someone else,
Ben convicted originally of this crime,
he would have never been out on the streets.
So now I live with this man,
got to do this man.
Now I got to deal with the fact that he didn't kill the man,
just just,
we'll just just attorney to put it on.
This man killed the man that shouldn't even been outside,
shouldn't even been three to rock around the hurt anybody again.
And he could have probably been very well lost.
His life was made him decide he needed to use physical force to kill them.
So it's so much debt,
so much responsibilities go into these cases and for us to say that we don't
have a system now that that decide,
we didn't seem enough crazy cases to us as adults and as,
as,
as people that shouldn't be responsible for criminal justice system.
We didn't seem enough outrageous behavior on just with the attorney to see this
do happen.
And it happened on a lot.
Well let me ask you this.
You,
you tried to hold the prosecutor accountable here,
right?
You,
you sued the District Attorney's office and you claim that not only had they
withheld this evidence in your case,
but that there was a whole group of cases there in New Orleans.
This was in New Orleans and this was a parish Orleans parish district attorney's
office,
which had had a number of cases reversed because of hiding evidence and
withholding evidence that showed innocence.
Uh,
tell us,
just got a limited amount of time,
but tell us what happened,
uh,
with regard to your lawsuit.
You know,
there's Kinda,
he's of weird,
cause it was,
it was a power clean in every aspect of it.
You know,
it was so politically he got to the parent with what was at stake hidden and
lost his value on what was really at stake hit and lost his value from the fact
that I come in and out of the all these Paris wellness happening,
most cases don't even make it to the docket.
Most kids get totally turned down saying that prosecutors have immunity.
All right.
This was so outrageous case and it was not only was this outrageous,
we had a former district attorney who had kind of had higher,
the oversee of grand jury investigation of his own office,
can't took conclusion that I can indict these five of y'all.
Why haven't these district attorneys,
Mr Carmine and Mr [inaudible] refused to accept him,
allow him that opportunity to do just that.
So he resigned.
We had him as our chief witness.
He was too sick.
All the corrupt nature that was happening inside of that system.
That's what the jury believed.
Not nothing that was said,
but what he invested in and what he discovered.
And when he said,
so the jury has said that it's no one to where Mr Kinda,
y'all continue to do this over and over and over again.
There's no inner world.
We are going to allow them to get away with this.
Here we gonna show y'all who was who'll just sit.
It's where this would it be and with the school to represent.
And so when the them responsible and rewarded us,
this what was amazing from there was the fifth circuit court of Appeals.
He's coming the first round of appeals where I win
back up the jury,
Greg gave you a verdict,
a $14 million,
is that right?
And add another million dollars to pay for the attorney's fee.
So you had a verdict of $15 million,
you appeared the state appeal that to the Orleans parish,
to the court of appeals,
which,
which divided evenly.
So that was upheld.
Uh,
and then it went to the
part of the United States.
That's it corrupts of the stone up in up edge.
You got to realize what we do in the winter,
especially when I feel circuit court of Appeals.
We got the night,
we don't know with it,
with his stuffed it in his messed up because just what happened,
my first round of appeals,
I wanted three Oh three judges was in my favorite deep,
the,
the bond hearing on them.
Three judges who was kind of override or the brother judges had been agreed that
this was less.
So somebody,
however he is done,
I don't know what the process is that we can override.
Three of our brothers,
dad made the decision on this case because when you call the Humboldt here,
that's what you was trying to do,
trying to override this decision.
So if that's a place out,
of course,
if I were right there,
that should be alone.
Is that a place where our criminal justice system is?
That's how our system was set up because some other judges don't agree with with
with these street judges,
who would we give a lifetime commitment to to do this job?
We say,
oh,
we didn't satisfy.
What did you send you?
So we're going to challenge the precision.
So we try to override it,
right?
And then we still hung with a divided coat.
So that's kind of crazy how you don't think,
think about that concept.
What this mean.
What I'm asking is this deep plane is kind of a game with that's important.
That's meaning,
it's not the people charged.
It's not.
It's not the will of the people.
If you go use your political power,
I would like to know who had that kind of power.
We need to know who the people are because if there's some decisions that really
affect the people,
this is how he set up this system in the world.
Not for you to have some other political power to pull that strength if you want
them and you just having to try to pull this down that you just didn't win,
but it was eight,
eight that's still messed up.
Came out when the jury verdict sustained,
right?
So what that means to the United States Supreme Court.
He shouldn't even been looking at it.
This isn't even a case.
United now are we to call it Haiyan.
It shouldn't be a case than United States supreme coaching even been trying to,
trying to see a hill,
but of course the concern with a dream,
nothing verdict.
Some buys this,
it was a state matter state issue itself.
[inaudible] itself.
It didn't come in there to the one with that one having a powerful pinion dead.
You know what?
We need to intervene here if three nothing.
They shouldn't even be reviewing it at all.
It was,
it was kind of crazy.
That deal was even revealing this at all period.
Let me ask you,
let me ask you this,
John Thompson,
uh,
when,
when were you released from,
uh,
from death row?
Um,
two or three made it feel coming up,
coming up next month.
Tell us what you've been doing and what adjustments you have been making to
going from being locked down and,
and Gola they're notorious who he is.
Yana state penitentiary.
Uh,
since you've been in the free world.
Well,
one of the,
one of the things we do is he falls lead to fight the system.
You know what,
you know,
once I took on the lawsuit and we conferenced stains that most people save,
it couldn't be done right now.
We got the whole world looking at wrongful conviction now,
you know,
we got them looking at prosecutor misconduct now we,
I didn't have a pound.
I didn't help pounders and maybe five or six different states.
Right now with the innocent project we've been on focusing on accountability put
on the arm,
you could go to the prosecutor oversight,
um,
and see some of the,
with the people that's holding,
supposed to be holding these people accountable.
What they are saying,
why are they not holding them accountable?
And you'll be shocked if,
you know,
if a judge said,
well I could see this district attorney don't know this bad stuff,
but I just kind of disciplining them because I know his family,
this is how eat,
you know,
in and in,
in reality of,
well forget about him killing an innocent man you are worrying about that's how
he takes care of his family.
So that is a real part of society that,
so it then God deep that we got to deal with.
We got done,
understand we got to learn.
So that been my biggest passion right now to like educate society about in most
cases we'd given these guys our life,
putting our life in the hands.
Surely we need to hold them accountable and we can't keep playing with this
premeditated thought of murder because when we can say,
of course it could pre plan and kill someone and you got a prosecutor who got to
use that same strategy to do that same thing.
If we could pull overwhelmingly that he had inflammation in his possession,
that this man was innocent.
Yeah,
he still pursued Mr. Bright.
You do know that since it's in phases,
it's a totally different trial.
So you to come out of that criminal and getting that conviction.
If as a prosecutor,
if you don't know,
you convicted in as a man,
you should have no by that time.
Right.
So if you're going to still use bad judgment from then on because you got a
conviction,
you got them off the streets for you to pursue the kill them.
You know,
it's kind of hard for me to person.
In your case,
it was pretty clear from the start.
Once they got those blood results,
you could not have committed that crime.
So here we got Jim Williams,
Jim prosecuted eight of us on debt,
put us all on death row out of Orleans parish,
even from holiday to Jefferson Paris.
Oh,
what's this home free right off of death row.
All of them that received some farmer reversal,
so that's just one man name is seven or eight different cases.
Then I look around and look at some of the other,
I see Jack people name and all of these other cases.
So you got individuals that deliberately did this over and over and over again
for our high end.
Cool look at this information and say,
oh,
this is not going on.
Oh,
y'all need to show a pattern for for how your to reverse eating one of these
cases on these type of serious issues and for the Bar Association or the
disciplinary board not to take up on himself at that punk.
It's doing complaint needs to be filed for as I'm concerned,
the how you cool.
Just not told you what happened to me that couldn't afford an attorney at all.
Why should it be on me to file a complaint against this a Tony?
Because it's obviously I didn't have a Tony before the court apparently mean
each Tony that I had.
So you asking me to file a complaint after all of this happened to me.
It's the only way you can consider
putting this person then discipline and I'm putting us in person and check,
no matter how many times he abuse it,
no matter how many times you tried to kill,
you know,
some people come on the rest of the respect yourself then you know,
however many times a day and showed up in these reversible cases at the same
name.
This man had a problem.
He should.
You told us a great deal about a failure to disclose and turn over evidence of
innocence.
You told us about accountability and about just a remarkable experience,
18 years of your life being taken away and the work you're doing now,
uh,
to,
to try to hold people accountable and to try to deal with this problem.
And as you say,
there are a number of other exonerated people.
And I know one of the other things you've been doing is working with people
who've been exonerated and are now released into the community.
Uh,
but I want to thank you for taking your time and being with us here today and
letting us know from a personal experience of someone who went through this and
experience this,
what it was like.
Thank you very much.
Thank you man.
Good to talk.
I love it.
Y'All report till y'all did an excellent report on prosecutor accountability
here.
I love you.
Thank you.
All right.